nos piden graficar el círculo y nos dan
justo esta expresión de aquí que en
principio se ve muy loca y que en este
en este digamos en este espacio
podemos graficar la verdad moviendo
tanto el centro como como nuestro radio
entonces para eso necesitamos saber
quién es justamente el centro y cuánto
vale su radio así que necesitamos poner
esta expresión de aquí arriba lo
necesitamos poner en una forma distinta
para saber tanto centro como el radio
así que voy a sacar mi programa de
dibujo ok ya estamos en el programa de
dibujo tenemos la misma ecuación que
teníamos anteriormente si puedes puedes
verificar lo que aquí está la misma
ecuación entonces lo que yo voy a hacer
esencialmente es completar cuadrados en
términos de x y en términos de ye para
ver una forma digamos reconocible que yo
pueda que yo pueda manipular entonces
voy a tomar los términos en x primero
que es x cuadrada menos 4x y voy a
ponerle un grande paréntesis porque un
paréntesis muy grande porque aquí yo voy
a añadir
para completar este digamos este para
hacer el cuadrado perfecto entonces
ahora también al grupo los que tienen ya
que son estos entonces voy a sumar de
cuadrada más 2 y voy a tener que agregar
algo para también tener un trinomio
cuadrado perfecto y bueno vamos a
agregar un color neutro aquí para restar
este 20 de aquí y esto lo igualamos a 0
muy bien entonces todo se reduce a
pensar que debo agregar en cada uno de
estos paréntesis para que esto se haga
un cuadrado perfecto y eso ya sabemos
hacerlo muy bien verdad simplemente
tomamos este coeficiente que es menos 4
dividimos entre 2 y me da menos 2
elevamos al cuadrado y eso es lo que
sumamos entonces aquí sumamos 4 muy bien
y esto y esto se puede factorizar
simplemente como x menos 2 que fue la
mitad de esto
cuadrado muy bien entonces si necesitas
repaso de esto hay muchísimos vídeos de
eso en la canacar de mí si no puedes
también desarrollar este cuadrado x2 x
x2 y vas a ver que nos da esto
simplemente es menos 2 x 2 es menos 4
por x es menos 4x y menos 2 al cuadrado
es 4 muy bien ahora si yo agregué 4 del
lado izquierdo
también debo agregar 4 del lado derecho
para que esta igualdad se conserve lo
mismo podemos hacer con esta expresión
para allí entonces dividimos 2 entre 2 y
nos da 1 que si lo elevamos al cuadrado
nos da 1 entonces esta expresión azul
simplemente se traduce en yemas 1 al
cuadrado muy bien entonces
para eliminar este 20 digamos podemos
sumar 20 de ambos lados por cierto antes
había que sumarle el 1 verdad había que
sumar este 1 que agregamos lo sumamos de
ambos lados
para eliminar este 20 sumó 20 también de
ambos lados entonces esto será igual a
41 que son 5 más 20 que son 25 muy bien
entonces esto ya es muy reconocible
justo es la fórmula de un círculo verdad
tenemos que x menos algo al cuadrado más
y menos otro algo al cuadrado es igual a
ere cuadrada donde el centro
inmediatamente me dice que es el punto
en el plano que tiene coordenadas a coma
b y el radio el radio simplemente es el
que tiene longitud r muy bien entonces
en este caso cuál cuál es el el centro
digamos aquí tenemos x menos 2 entonces
nuestra primera coordenada va a ser 2 y
la segunda tenemos ye más uno que eso es
que menos menos uno entonces aquí será
menos uno y ahí tenemos las coordenadas
de nuestro centro y simplemente hay que
recordar que estos son los valores que
al sustituirlos
y me hacen que esto sea 0 y esto también
verdad ahora quién sería el radio el
radio pues si tenemos que el radio que
25 es el radio al cuadrado entonces el
radio es la raíz cuadrada de 25 que es 5
entonces r es igual a 5 así que vamos a
regresar a nuestro ejercicio hay que
acordarnos que es 2 menos uno y el radio
5 entonces regresamos al ejercicio el
centro está en dos equis igualados y
igual a menos uno y el radio cinco
entonces hay que extenderlo 1 2 3 4 y 5
y comprobamos la respuesta y la tuvimos
bastante bien